real he'll never find the answer you're
seeking if you just proceed blindly take
some time stop and think on your path
ponder where you've been and ultimately
where your fists will lead you ponder my
fists if you keep loafing around like
you are we you will get ahead of you I
understand that master I'm gonna work
harder and become much stronger hmm
looks like you got laid out again huh
anyway it's amazing how you always find
great places like this settings like
this help me concentrate oh hey you've
been covered already yes Ken if it's no
trouble would you practice with me a
while I want to take another look at my
fist that thing that master was saying
the essence of the fist is the core of
fighting right sure thing let's get to
it
let's see you try and dodge this one
ok
good hey let's get back I'm starving
here no I have something that I want to
try out something like what
I'm starting to feel something
haha I don't know what's this feeling
you're chasing but I hope you try and
figure it out
mikey is charged now I can't put real
skiers
whoo I'm completely exhausted yeah but
this was fun so then did you get a good
look at your fist
good enough to learn that I still have a
long way to go huh I see
close been